This is kind of a funny coda to the Trump
bleach injection fiasco after Trump wondered
aloud about whether disinfectants like isopropyl
alcohol and bleach could be injected or otherwise
introduced into the body to treat Corona virus,
a whole bunch of Trump is denied that he said
it the next day.
Trump admitted to saying it, but he claimed
it was sarcasm.
And then he took no press questions at a press
briefing later that day.
And Trump ists are now dealing with conflicting
defenses.
What some are saying, he never said it.
Others are saying it was sarcasm.
And Trump admitted to saying it and says it
was sarcasm.
But it doesn't appear Trump knows what sarcasm
is.
Maybe shockingly, longtime Fox News and Fox
Business anchor Neil CAVUTO.
Plain and simple.
Just admitted Trump wasn't joking.
This wasn't sarcasm.
And it's extra funny, by the way, to hear
Neil CAVUTO reading the quote off of a transcript.
Let's let's indulge together remarks yesterday
when he talked about injecting people with
disinfectant.
Nor were we imagining the incredulous looks
he got from his medical team when he made
the suggestion there was nothing in those
comments yesterday that hinted of the dismissal
he was giving today.
Now, he did waver, decide that that was not
what he intended, but that is what he said,
that injecting people with disinfectant or
coronavirus showed some great promise.
He said, I think you said you're going to
test that, too.
And it sounds interesting.
He went on to say that I see that, in fact,
disinfectant, where it knocks it out in a
minute.
In one minute.
Is there a way we can do something like that
by injection inside or almost a cleaning?
Because you see it gets in the lungs.
Here is referring to the Corona virus and
it does a tremendous number on the lungs,
again, referring to the Corona virus.
You said it would be interesting to check
that so that you're going to have to use medical
doctors with this.
But it it sounds interesting to me.
He is talking about injecting products like
Lysol into your body to see if that can combat
the disease.
That is what he said.
Now, he might be dialing that back today.
I don't know why.
He just didn't say, look, I screwed up.
I got it wrong.
That wasn't my intention.
This is an important medical distinction.
So much so that the makers of Lysol came out
and said, no, no, no, no, no.
Do not inject our product in to your body.
Notice how Neil CAVUTO says Trump should have
just said, hey, I got it wrong.
I was just wrong on this one.
Where is Neil CAVUTO been for the last 20
years and especially the last three and a
half with Donald Trump as president?
Has Trump ever just showed up and said, I
misspoke, I was wrong about X, Y and Z?
No, he took a Sharpie and modified a weather
map when saying I was just wrong would have
been the right thing to do.
Now, one other thing about CAVUTO.
CAVUTO actually goes on to debunk Trump's
claim that only Chinese studies are saying
hydroxy chloroquine might be bad for people
taking corona virus.
Here's.
Kabuto saying this is data from our own FDA
that says it might be time to cut it with
the hydroxy.
Secondly, he goes on to say on these findings
there, still unresolved on Drug Seglora claim
and chloroquine.
It was the FDA, not a study in China that
said that coded 19 outside of hospital settings
or clinical trials is is not to be combined
with any treatments of Heider.
Dr. calorically or calorically that that having
them outside of these venues there is a high
risk of heart rhythm problems.
I just want to very clarify that these were
not some outside entities.
This was the FDA saying, well, we'll go outside
of these settings.
There are risks.
So this other study that it's got some worried
that maybe the president was trying to dismiss,
that has to do with the use of this to treat
to treat those with this condition.
Now, the president has often said that the
drops include getting these others.
What have you got to lose?
Well, in a V.A. study of a few hundred of
our veterans, the risk is they have to lose
their lives.
Neil CAVUTO has, of course, since been fired
by Fox News.
I'm kidding.
But I do want to be careful here, because
CAVUTO has been a vector of disinformation
for decades on Fox News.
He's been on Fox News for 23, 20, I think
since day one since 1996.
So we don't need to go out of our way to praise
him.
Big picture, the same way that just because
Trump is wildly more cartoonishly sic than
Bush was.
We don't need to go out of our way to praise
George W. Bush.
But CAVUTO spent a bunch of Friday's show
debunking Trump's lies, which is good because
that's the audience that needs to hear it
most, most acutely.
The other angle is that we're increasingly
seeing Fox concern just about the legal repercussions
of how they've portrayed Corona virus from
day one.
There's a study released last week that suggests
if you watch Sean HANNITY more than Tucker,
you were more likely to get the virus, which
sort of tracks with HANNITY being much more
flippant and minimizing of the risk from Corona
virus so that this stuff has a real impact.
If Neil CAVUTO really wanted to do the full
story, it would include mentioning that if
Trump was joking when he said inject bleach,
that's one question.
But if he was joking, what is the joke like?
What's the punchline?
They're watching.
This is a very weird experience because the
tone of Neil Cavuto's voice is almost like
he's surprised that Trump lied multiple times
during the press briefing.
Trump's been lying during every single one
of these press briefings since day one.
Good for Neil CAVUTO for calling out to lies
that it was sarcastic and that Hydroxy is
working, but still big picture.
Neil CAVUTO seemed surprised that these press
briefings are nothing but opportunities to
disseminate lies and disinformation.
We're going to have clips from all of this
on our Instagram page.
So make sure you're following us on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
I also on my personal Instagram will be posting
a time lapse of my tomato plants rising like
the Phenix to like about an inch sprout.
Anyway, that's on my Instagram at David Pakman.